[Music]
how would you draw a
scientist this question has been posed
to students from all grade levels to
understand how people perceive the field
of science when the experiment was
initially conducted in the 1960s and
1970s the majority of students Drew
white middle-aged men with lab coats
while more students are drawing female
scientists in the 21st century a gender
gap still exists in stem fields in
addition to gender identity science
lacks representation in other areas like
race ethnicity physical ability sexual
orientation and socioeconomic
status including these identities is
essential for making science beneficial
to and reflective of our diverse
Society why are diversity and inclusion
important in
stem while science historically
emphasizes the single lone person making
important discoveries in reality teams
of people are responsible for the most
impactful
research within these teams different
perspectives Drive scientific and
technological
innovation using an interdisciplinary
approach researchers found that
diversity matters more than ability when
solving complex problems another study
concluded that diversity may even
produce higher quality
science the identities of researchers
can influence their ideas and
subsequently the status quo of science
historically groups of scientists of the
same or similar predominant identities
have supported misinterpretation of
scientific findings and inaccurate
scientific
conclusions for instance white male
scientists arguing for the superiority
of their own race promoted scientific
racism and Eugenics which became
widespread beliefs and led to harmful
policies globally scientists with a
diversity of backgrounds can prevent
harm from occurring
in fact underrepresented minorities
specifically black and brown students
tend to Value social justice more than
their non-urm
peers however there are several barriers
that not only prevent diversity and
inclusion from happening but also
encourage like-mindedness within
stem Gatekeepers such as guidance
counselors teachers faculty members
recruiters and managers have the ability
to support or prevent the pursuit of a
stem career and may enforce negative
biases additionally as individuals with
underrepresented identities climb the
academic and professional ladder they
continue to face challenges along with
lower pay and less professional respect
their ideas are less likely to be
accepted by the scientific Community
compared to white able-bodied men white
researchers are also more likely to
receive funding for their studies
compared to those of color the legacy of
inequality in science although less
overt is still present in our society
with discrimination and Prejudice
disproportionately affecting
historically underrepresented identities
to make stem more diverse and inclusive
systemic Solutions are needed
acknowledging and supporting different
perspectives in stem can enact change
from the inside
out integrating non-western approaches
into scientific standards is one way to
achieve this for instance traditional
ecological knowledge or information
acquired by generations of indigenous
populations has been increasingly
recognized within modern science with
applications in Pharmacology and
Wildlife preservation recognizing the
accomplishments of those belonging to
underrepresented minorities is also
important for example the American
mathematical Society has emphasized
increasing the diversity of its prize
committees to increase the diversity of
Award nominees and
winners it is important for industry and
Academia to focus on equity and instead
of equality when creating systemic
Solutions rather than providing the same
opportunities to everyone Equity ensures
fairness making adjustments based on
pre-existing
imbalances to identify structural issues
and imbalances that prevent
inclusion leaders and stakeholders can
use equity
audits Equity audits collect data on how
resources are distributed throughout an
organization's demographics as a result
they can help determine the
institutional practices that lead to
discriminatory
outcomes Equity audits are only a tool
however organizations and institutions
must Implement intentional policies
based on their
findings another approach is holistic
review in hiring practices it can reduce
bias and strict or unspoken rules making
the candidate pool more
inclusive this can translate into more
researchers and Prof professionals
belonging to identities in the inclusive
workplace additionally allowing
flexibility within stem can support
inclusion extending the 10e timeline for
instance provides accommodation for
extenda family or personal
circumstances Equity is an ongoing
process and Industry and Academia must
constantly work to promote diversity and
inclusion and providing continuous
education for Gatekeepers at all levels
is a crucial step in this
process to increase representation
initiatives that are accessible to
everyone including groups with
underrepresented identities and stem
need to be created and invested
in financial aid in general is an
effective tool with a 2016 study finding
that the availability of need-based aid
for college ready students may increase
the completion of stem courses by up to
33% and a stem degree by up to
60% high impact practices
such as undergraduate research and
community- based learning have
significant educational benefits for
everyone engaged in them and especially
those underrepresented in
stem paid internships another high
impact practice can reduce the barriers
for low-income students and the US White
House implemented this for the first
time in recent history in
2022 while mentorship can increase
belonging in stem it is important that
diversity and inclusion initiatives do
not rely solely on mentorship as it can
place even more stress on mentors
belonging to underrepresented identities
everyone should be able to participate
in and benefit from science however
there is still a problem with
accessibility in
stem this leaves Innovative Minds
unutilized limiting human capital and
preventing science from progressing
further diversity and inclusion go hand
inand to make science have the greatest
impact
possible
[Music]